en mai 2010 est à monza en italie et you
keep choquée avait raté son objectif par
à peine 26 secondes
aujourd'hui le kenyan de 34 ans se croit
mieux disposés pour relever ce colossal
défi mais ils n'offrent aucune garantie
de résultat
event phase test car guantanamo
le champion olympique en titre détenteur
depuis un an du record du monde en 2
heures une minute et 39 secondes fait
cette fois équipe avec le géant de la
pétrochimie ineos afin de franchir 42,2
km en moins de 120 minutes
crypto gay s'élancera à 8h15 samedi
matin soit deux jours 15 à l'heure du
québec
on prévoit un ciel dégagé à vienne et
une température d'environ 10 degrés des
conditions jugées idéal le parcours au
coeur du parc du prater présente un
circuit plat de 9,6 km que les coureurs
franchiront approximativement quatre
fois et demi la qualité de l'air y est
élevée dit ans sans compter que la route
et protégés du vent par les arbres 41
coureurs parmi les plus prestigieux de
la planète ont été engagés pour épauler
crypto gay dans sa quête ils se
relaieront par groupe de 10 autour de
lui derrière une voiture qui avancera au
rythme d'un km en 2 minutes 50 en raison
de ces conditions spéciales
l'exploit ne sera pas homologué par la
fédération internationale d'athlétisme
keep you gilad mais cette expérience
n'est pas un véritable marathon
mais elle a une grande valeur à ses yeux
fermés michel chabot radio canada
montréal